sn1 and sn2 described two different
competing mechanisms for a substitution
reaction in general the reaction looks
like this a compound containing a
leaving group on an sp3 carbon reacts
with a nucleophile and essentially the
groups switch places the nucleophile
adds to the organic molecule and the
leaving group is displaced this looks
simple enough but it gets complex pretty
quickly that's because we have these two
competing mechanisms let's look at the
ways in which this reaction can occur
mechanistically now we'll begin with sn2
because that mechanism is actually less
steps we'll start with this alkyl
chloride now I realize I have two
methyls on this so this compound is not
chiral but I'm going to draw the
chlorine like it's pointing up just to
illustrate a point here for this simple
example our nucleophile is the anion of
this sulfur compound so this might be n
asme so a sodium salt of this sulfur
anion and the sodium can of course be
thought of as a spectator ion so we're
just gonna look at the structure of this
negatively charged nucleophile here in a
single concerted step concerted means
that all the bonds are gonna break and
form at the same time the sulfur attacks
carbon now remember there's an implied
hydrogen atom right where we're making
our new bond so carbon already has four
bonds we cannot make five bonds to
carbon so chlorine has to leave now
since all these bonds are being formed
and broken at the same time the sulfur
needs to approach exactly opposite the
chlorine atom in the sn2 mechanism
inversion of stereochemistry has
resulted the stereochemistry changed at
that Center of course in this reaction
we also get our chloride ion that has
been displaced now let's take a peek at
the mechanism of our sn1 reaction we'll
begin with this chiral Brome I treat it
with acetic acid
and we're going to get replacement of
our bromine with the acetic acid however
in this case we get two products we get
this compound resulting from inversion
of stereochemistry but we also get this
compound where the acetate has added but
it has retention of stereochemistry both
the bromine and the acetate groups are
pointing up so what happened here well
in this mechanism the first step is the
leaving group leaving on its own bromine
departs the molecule and that forms an
intermediate carbo cation now only once
we get this carbo cation forming can the
acetic acid or its conjugate base
acetate attack and form these products
carbo cations are planar trigonal planar
at this centre and so this can now be
attacked from the front face or the back
face if we imagine it attacking through
the bottom of this piece of paper here
if the incoming nucleophile approaches
again from the top
we get retention of configuration if it
comes through the bottom we'll get this
inversion of configuration since each of
these mechanisms gives rise to very
different stereochemistry of products
it's important that we're able to
distinguish whether an sn1 or sn2
mechanism is going to occur and there's
a few factors that will go into this
determination
the first factor that we'll consider is
the most important and that is substrate
structure there are also solvent effects
that play into these reactions the
strength of the nucleophile that we use
will also play a big role and finally
the ability of this leaving group to
leave the molecule is also going to be
an important factor let's begin with our
examination of substrate structure to be
consistent we're going to look at a
bunch of bromides here we'll begin by
examining these four bromides if you're
wondering why this guy is all the way
over here we're gonna fill in some stuff
later okay
methylbromide this is the first
substrate will consider containing only
a methyl group and our leaving group
our next halide is primary this halide
here is secondary and our guy way over
here is tertiary now in this sn1
mechanism we form a carbo cation so it's
really important to think about the
carbo cation that can form from each of
these substrates and actually let's
start with tertiary first so here's our
carbo cation a tertiary carbo cation
this is quite stable due to an effect
called hyper conjugation if I redraw the
cation and then draw out one of these
ch3 groups hanging off of it there's
actually stabilization of the carbo
cation that can occur from the electrons
in these CH bonds and in all of the ones
that I haven't drawn out so we get a lot
of stabilization of this carbo cation by
an effect that we call hyper conjugation
on the opposite end of the spectrum this
methyl bromide if it were to form a
carbo cation spoiler alert it doesn't
we're gonna draw this one in red it
would look like this since it's these
nearby bonds that offer the
stabilization to the carbo cation this
has none of that we just have a carbon
with all hydrogen's around it and this
carbo cation cannot form primary is
really bad to our primary carbo cation
would look like this we have one ch3
hanging off here doesn't offer a lot of
stabilization okay so what is this
telling us well our tertiary halide is
great at forming carbo cations really
stable carbo cations since the sn1
mechanism goes through this carbo cation
intermediate this substrate does sn1
chemistry and for reasons we'll go into
in a moment it only does sn1 now our
little red carbo cations over here they
are not stable and so for these
substrates the only mechanism available
is sn2
which doesn't go through a carbo cation
intermediate now what about our
secondary substrate the carbo cation
that it would form looks like this and
if you can guess from me drawing this in
blue it's pretty stable this is where
this chemistry gets a little bit complex
because even though this simple
secondary bromide here is very reluctant
to undergo at an sn1 reaction this
substrate can actually do both under
different conditions so this might go
sn1 or sn2 depending on these factors
okay in this blank part of our table
let's fill in some substrates that might
be a little bit newer to you this is an
allyl group and this compound has a lil
bromide this substrate here is benzylic
a benzyl group is the phenyl ring and
this carbon this compound is called
benzyl bromide let's look at the carbo
cation that forms with a lil bromide now
this might look close to primary but we
have something special going on here and
that special thing is resonance this
resonance stabilizes this carbo cation
so much that even primary ll substrates
can undergo sn1 but judging from the
positioning on this chart this is also
an intermediate case ll substrates can
undergo sn1 or sn2 mechanisms the
benzylic carbo cation looks like this
this carbo cation has extensive
resonance stabilization I'll let you
look up those structures but there are
four contributing structures to this
carbo cation this is also a substrate
that can do either sn1 or sn2 depending
on the reaction conditions okay so I
want to back up just for a second and
tell you why the sn1 and sn2 reactions
are named the way that they are in the
sn2 reactions we have this single
reaction step well when we have one step
that is the rate determining step of the
reaction so the rate is determined by
this nucleophile coming in and pushing
out our leaving group that rate depends
on both of the
these reagents two molecules are
involved in the rate-determining step
so sn2 stands for substitution
nucleophilic by molecular two substrates
reacting in this step in the sn1
reaction well the rate determining step
this sits around until the leaving group
leaves and then this step is going to be
really fast we have a positively charged
thing that's going to be attracted to
electrons and they come together really
quick here but this thing just sits
around until this leaves and so this
first step is our slow step or our rate
determining step so in an sn1 reaction
the rate only is determined by this
compound and how long it sits around
until it gives up its leaving group and
then the rest of the reaction proceeds
rapidly so substitution nucleophilic
unimolecular we can draw a reaction
coordinate diagram for each of these
reactions I'll begin with the reaction
coordinate for the sn2 reaction being a
one-step process it's going to be
simpler so energy is increasing on this
axis and this just tells us what's gonna
happen as the reaction kind of moves in
this direction we'll draw our substrate
over here and for an exothermic process
our product will sit at a lower energy
so here are our respective energy levels
and our reaction will pass through a
high energy point to produce this
product at this high energy point we
have the transition state of the
reaction and the energy that we have to
overcome to get to that transition state
is the activation energy now the
transition state we we don't have an
intermediate here it's just this kicks
this out all in one step the transition
state is the part of the reaction where
partial bonds have actually formed and
bonds are breaking we can't really
detect this it's not an intermediate but
it's going to happen along the process
and bonds are being kind of stretched
and new bonds are partially formed
we can depict this as looking something
like this okay so for this reaction we
have the chlorine just starting to leave
and the SME is coming in and starting to
form this bond this has to become kind
of flat in the middle here so I have
this one sticking up I'm showing the
methyl sticking out at U and the H is
going back and so I think this really
shows you how we're getting inversion of
configuration here this methyl has to
approach from the back this is sometimes
called backside attack the SME is coming
in kicking out the chlorine from the
exact opposite face and that's why I
drew this pointing up here and this
pointing down a reaction coordinate for
the sn1 reaction looks different so
again assuming an exothermic reaction
where the products are lower energy than
the reactants we're still going to have
to traverse a high energy point but then
we get this intermediate along the
pathway so in this case we get a lower
energy dip in the middle where our carbo
cation intermediates it's okay I think
looking at these energy diagrams sets us
up to consider how solvent affects sn1
and sn2 reactions now solvents for both
of these reactions are going to be polar
but in the case of the sn2 reaction
we're going to use polar protic solvents
so a protic means polar solvents that
cannot donate a proton to anything
examples of this are dimethyl formamide
or DMF DMSO dimethyl sulfide and Osito
nitrile there are many more examples
these are just a few notice that each of
them has polar atoms in it that'll
create a dipole in the molecule
effectively solubilizing these compounds
and the ions that form but we don't have
any protons here now the sn1 reaction is
often run in polar protic solvents some
examples of this are methanol and we
have the proton here
water is a great polar protic solvent
and another example is acetic acid that
we used in this reaction let's look just
a little bit deeper at the solvent
effects and how polar protic solvents
are going to speed up the rate of sn1
reactions in order to speed up the rate
the solvent must be affecting the rate
determining step which for this reaction
is the ionization of our bromide now
we've shown a single curved arrow to
depict the bromine leaving and forming
this carbo cation
however this substrate isn't just
waiting around to pop off its bromide at
any given moment we're going to have the
solvent assisting this process so right
before the bromine pops off of this
molecule we might think about this bond
elongating a little bit a bit of
positive charge will start building up
on this carbon and this leaving group
will start to take on some negative
character and now let's just imagine
that there's water as solvent in this
reaction the water molecules can orient
their Delta negative side toward the
forming positive charge stabilizing its
formation the water can also stabilize
the negative charge forming on this
bromide as it's starting to leave as it
becomes Delta minus the water can orient
its Delta positive hydrogen atoms toward
the leaving group and once that leaving
group leaves the water molecules do a
good job of keeping the ions in solution
by solvating them very well in the sn2
reaction we're stabilizing this
transition state with the nucleophile
forming a partial bond and the leaving
group leaving with a partial bond they
both have some negative character on
them so it's preferable to have a polar
solvent since we have some dipoles
forming and we're gonna be forming ions
in this reaction but we don't want the
solvent to be protic well we have to
think about why that is in order to
achieve this transition state the
electrons on this nucleophile
to be available let's imagine putting
this nucleophile into a solution of the
polar protic solvent methanol this anion
is now strongly solvated by all of these
hydrogen bonds and the activation energy
to achieve this transition state in a
solvent like this becomes much greater
so we still need to use a polar solvent
this has a lot of charge and we need to
dissolve it and keep it in solution
however we don't want to use something
that is polar and protic because it will
tie up our nucleophile just too much